growing concern about a new sub-variant
of omicron now the dominant cobot strain
in the u.s it's called ba2 and according
to the cdc it makes up more than 72
percent of positive cases nationwide so
let's bring in dr celine gander editor
at large for public health at kaiser
health news and an infectious disease
specialist and epidemiologist dr gowner
good morning uh i guess we should point
out uh it's great to see you well
because the last time we met like this i
was unknowingly covered positive and
found out about five minutes after you
left set so you're healthy i am healthy
aren't you like good to see you tonight
but now you can be pretty confident that
i'm in good shape
you know get that immunity the
old-fashioned way yes yes um i wanted to
begin with a general question which is
the governments of our country seem to
be putting responsibility back on
individuals to decide how to handle the
uh pandemic so how should people be
thinking through both their personal
risk and how they expose others well i
think that's precisely how you should
break it down what is my personal risk
so what is my personal health risk what
is my personal job risk so for example
you and i if we have coveted we can't be
on set if i have coveted i can't be at
my job in the hospital and then finally
what is the risk to the most vulnerable
people in your life so maybe it's your
grandmother maybe it's that
six-month-old child so i think that's
how i break down how do you how do you
think about the risk
the cdc does have a website that um
shows you community transmission and
community risk i would be careful in
interpreting those numbers that green
yellow red it really tells you if you
get sick the hospitals will be able to
take care of me with normal standards of
care versus crisis standards of care i
just don't trust their personal
responsibility i don't think people to
take the tell the truth about it now you
can go to restaurants you can go
anywhere they're not asking to see your
vaccines anymore so you're in a room
with a bunch of people you don't know if
they're vaccinated not vaccinate how are
we supposed to move in the world these
days who are we supposed to trust what
are we supposed to do good question
yeah it's a great question i mean the
only people we can ultimately trust to
ourselves and knowing that we can do the
right thing we can get vaccinated if we
have symptoms we can get tested if we're
infected that we stay home from work or
we don't go to school i think things are
about to get a whole lot harder for
people though the government funding for
testing and vaccination
treatment for people who did not have
insurance that money has run out and so
now you're going to start having to pay
for things out of your own pocket yeah
there's another new sub variant of
omicron called xc that was uh found in
the uk should we be concerned about it
here in the u.s
i wouldn't get too alarmed about this
just yet it's basically a cross between
the original omicron and this new ba.2
omicron
we don't know a lot about it yet but it
doesn't really seem to be more of a
threat than the original omicrons so
cases are declining here but they're
rising in the uk and there's been a
shanghai lockdown um are is what is
happening overseas a sign of things to
come for us it could be it's a little
early to say i would i would look to the
uk as the best
predictor of what may be in store for us
uh and there are some concerning signs
so they are better vaccinated than we
are especially their elderly are better
vaccinated and boosted and of course
they're the ones that are highest risks
and we're seeing hospitalizations go up
nevertheless in the uk so we are sort of
you know on watch and we'll see what
happens where do you stand on that
fourth booster because now they're
saying people 50 and over should get it
do you do a do you think that's that you
need to do that do you think everybody
should get it and if you do is it okay
to mix the vaccines does that make a
difference so if you're over 50 and you
want a booster you can absolutely get a
booster the the recommendations you do
yeah yeah the recommendations are if
you're over 50 and you have a chronic
underlying medical condition let's say
diabetes uh that you absolutely should
get that fourth dose not everybody knows
if they have one of those underlying
medical conditions and so that's why the
guidance is pretty flexible but what if
you're over 50 and you're healthy
yeah do you think you should get it i
think that's really up to you and your
personal you know discretion depending
on your sense of risk but you are
absolutely eligible if you're over 50 to
go get one but are you better covered
that's what i'm saying you know i'm
clearly i'm over 50 but i'm thinking are
you better covered if you get it or does
it make a difference that's what i'm
trying to fix yeah so if you've already
had three doses you get a fourth dose
the data from israel shows you have a
temporary maybe three to four month
boost in your immunity
that's it on top of what you already
have so i think the key message is that
your three
doses already do a lot to protect you
dr celine gander thank you so much
valuable information and gail i would
have thought early 40s